danger street is a Prestige TV series in  comic book form  [Music]  DC put out a trade called first issue  specials which was a thing that happened  in the mid 70s they made 13 of these  issues each one is a different  somewhat brand new DC concept and it's  the weirdest stuff DC ever made and I  was like what if all these people  existed in the same world but I came up  with this huge story that involved all  of them from the Green Team to the  dingbats of danger Street to Lady cop to  the creeper we can make this into  something huge and big and epic Jorge  and I have worked together in Batman we  worked together on Rorschach and so this  is sort of our third Journey out this is  a book that doesn't live without Jorge  Hornes dealing with 20 plus characters  who are all doing different things each  of them needs to be sort of modernized  but also classic at the same time it  starts off it gets you calm and then by  the end of the issue one it like punches  you in the gut  [Music]